à la boîte vous êtes vus appartenu au
groupe surréaliste ce qui est bizarre
c'est que vous avez adhéré au groupe
surréaliste au moment où pratiquement
tout le monde ne le quittait où vous été
mis à la porte ou le kit est injustement
sépare parce qu'il me semblait que
c'était à ce moment-là que je pouvais
dire que moi enfin j'étais plutôt
d'accord avec eux c'est à dire que je me
suis posée à peu près les mêmes
problèmes que peut se poser les
surréalistes les spams et j'étais
contrôleur le côté un peu théâtral enfin
le les tréteaux enfin et les
manifestations un peu bout de champ et
pour l'occasion il avait parfaitement
raison de verre puisque tel était leur
tempérament
mais quant à moi ça ne me convenait pas
si bien que je les suivais d'un peu loin
aux pages assister parfois aux
manifestations est arrivé d'assister à
des manifestations bruyantes de
surréaliste j'ai assisté par d'un
première de poussière de soleil ou des
choses comme ça où des pièces de berthod
de vitrac souvient de ça mais je
n'assistais mais je ne je ne faisais pas
partie du groupe
c'est au moment même où beaucoup ont
quitté le groupe ne sais pas où
après le second cadavre en vacances
quand il ya eu une attaque violente des
d'un grand manque de surréaliste dont
plusieurs avaient d'ailleurs du talent
n'est ce pas beaucoup de talent on put
est brillamment
le groupe que cache ce moment là et
enfin j'ai écrit autant à gand et lui a
alors disons vous inquiétez pas c'est
vous qui avez du talent plus que les
autres et je viens avec vous il ya
longtemps que je vous suis que ce que
vous faites m'intéresse et maintenant
c'est le moment pour moi de vous le dire
mais comme vous ne fait rien comme les
autres vous quittez ensuite le groupe
surréaliste gila sur la pointe des pieds
sans père alors que tous les gens qui
quittent le nom sur la liste avec pertes
et fracas et vous tout à fait doucement
mais pourquoi vous l'avez quittée pour
une maison parfaitement surréaliste à
laquelle c'est parce que j'aime et une
une jeune fille qui est d'ailleurs
devenue ma femme et je m'occupais que de
ça avant les que je larache sa famille
et enfin que deux je l'obtienne et je ne
m'occupais exactement que de ça c'est
donc une raisons parfaitement
surréaliste
vous avez occupé entièrement par l'amour
ah oui j'avais à faire de ce côté là il
fallait que je fasse ça mais je les ai
pas du tout piqué de me fâcher avec oui
c'est ça c'est bien ce que j'aime étude
ne lui ment pas et vous êtes entré à ce
moment là aux messageries achète et vous
dit quelque part qui est fait à l'est
que j'ai une profession pour pour que
les parents de ma femme
enfin enfin de celle dont je voulais
faire ma femme mais accepte enfin
c'était pas du tout hein
un écrivain après notoire n'est ce pas
même pas du tout pas seulement par
quelques petits groupes et s'avoue
toutefois qu'il n'avait aucune
profession qu'il aurait pu consentir
il avait parfaitement raison je suis
donc entré dans ce bagne et qu'on
appelait les messageries